The next category of patterns, in the Gang of Four book, are the structural
patterns of which the composite pattern is example we've already seen.
Some other ones that are provided include the adapter pattern which you
would use to convert an existing interface to look like another interface.
The bridge pattern, in which you decouple an abstraction and implementation.
The decorator pattern, in which you would add a single feature to an existing
class. The facade pattern, which provides a higher-level interface for
a subsystem. This might typically be used in a situation where you
have some non-object oriented legacy code, which you'd want to access from
within an object oriented application. And you need to make it look like
an object oriented interface. The flyweight pattern allows you to use sharing to
support large number of fine-grained objects. So imagine a situation, for
example, when you're doing text processing, and each of the characters you'd
like to treat as an object. Well, this can be quite expensive, because, because,
there, because be tens of thousands of such objects. Instead flyweight,
allows provides you a way of doing this without creating all those objects.
Finally the proxy pattern allows you to control access to an object.